[music playing]
NARRATOR: And while
sharks have always
been present along this massive
shoreline, starting in 2010,
they become a problem.
More than 60 attacks
in just 10 years,
triple the number of incidents
from the preceding decade--
it's an unprecedented uptick.
Shark attacks in Western
Australia previously were rare.
Now they're almost
regular events.
NARRATOR: Not only that, the
spike includes a horrifying 11
fatalities, earning this tourist
haven a terrifying designation
as Australia's deadliest coast.
[dramatic music]
TREVOR WHYTE: The amount
of vicious attacks--
there's no question.
It becomes talk of the town.
People are scared to
go back in the water.
NARRATOR: With residents
demanding action,
authorities put
prevention measures
in place, including
aerial surveillance
and beach enclosures.
But the attacks
just keep coming.
So investigators take
up the case in a bid
to stop the bloodshed and keep
it from recurring elsewhere.
BLAKE CHAPMAN: The more we can
research into what's happening,
then the more human
fatalities and human trauma
we're going to be
able to prevent.
NARRATOR: So what's causing
the sharks of Western Australia
to suddenly go on a rampage?
Shark expert Johann
Gustafson believes
that a crucial first step
in solving this mystery
is to identify the culprit.
So he turns to a
piece of evidence
from the attack on Elyse.
So here we have a
fragment of tooth that
was lodged within the victim.
NARRATOR: Gustafson thinks
this tooth must belong to one
of three species which are
responsible for the majority
of the attacks worldwide.
The first is the tiger shark.
[dubstep music]
So here we have
a tiger shark jaw.
And we see on one
side of the jaw,
the blades are
pointing to the left,
where on the opposite
side of the jaw,
they're pointing in
the opposite direction.
NARRATOR: This allows
tigers to rip their prey
from both sides of their
teeth as they shake
their heads back and forth.
A second likely culprit
is the bull shark.
[dubstep music]
JOHANN GUSTAFSON: So
with our bull shark,
we have here a completely
different shape of tooth.
Quite pointed, serration
is quite sharp.
NARRATOR: The bull shark's
powerful pointed teeth
enable it to slice
through its victim
in one quick lethal motion.
But Gustafson believes the shape
of the tooth from Elyse's wound
indicates a different predator.
With this tooth fragment,
it's perfectly triangular.
And it's quite
serrated on both sides.
Without doubt, I can conclude
this came from a white shark.
[electronic music]
NARRATOR: Great
whites are the largest
predatory fish on the planet.
They use their powerful tails
to propel them through the water
at upwards of 25
miles per hour, often
striking their prey from below.
But this identification isn't
limited to Elyse's attacker.
Of the more than 60 attacks
where the species is known,
the majority of culprits
are white sharks.
So what's causing great whites
here to act so strangely?
And could it be indicative
of a behavioral shift
happening across the globe?
Perhaps the answer relates
to a booming industry that's
centered around
this iconic species,
one that occurs in
several locations but all
began down under--
cage diving.
Shark expert Dr.
Dan Huber explains.
The way cage diving
operations work
is that boats use chum to try
and attract sharks to the area.
People then get into
cages, which are submerged
in the water, to get much, much
closer to very dangerous sharks
than they would
otherwise be able to.
NARRATOR: Cage diving has been
a fixture of Australian tourism
for decades.
But around 2010,
something changed.
DAN HUBER: In 2010, when the
spike in shark attacks began,
the number of days that
chumming occurred on the water
had doubled compared
to the previous year.